hey guys do you sometimes
overthink things and you get anxiety
some of you ask me daniel how do you
handle overthinking and anxiety i need
some help give me some tips well first
off you need to know that if this is
happening to you you're not alone it
happens to a lot of people out there
research studies by the university of
michigan show that overthinking is a
national epidemic among young and
middle-aged adults but is relatively
rare among older adults 73
of 25 to 35 year olds overthink compared
to 52 percent of 45 to 55 year olds and
just 20 percent of 65 to 75 year olds
so why do you overthink so much and what
can you do to stop overthinking and
anxiety well in this video i'm gonna
tell you what i do to stop overthinking
and to control my thoughts let's get to
it
[Music]
all right guys so why are you
overthinking so much well it might be
because of a combination of things the
way you grew up
your dna
your personality type and the season
that you're in in your life right now
and most people who want to control
everything they have a real hard time
to stop
not to have anxiety and not trying to
overthink things all the time because
they want to control everything they
develop this habit of thinking like oh
man what what should i do if this
happens or what if that happens or what
if this person says that or oh man what
am i gonna
they think about things all the time
because they cannot let go
and then on the other hand some people
can't let go of the past
they think things like man i should have
done this differently that differently
i made a mistake back then my life could
have been so much better right now if i
didn't do that
now first of all you need to understand
that this kind of thinking
it is destructive because it is not
helping you in the now
it is holding you back you're wasting
unnecessary time on it
and it's preventing you from moving on
you can never change the past but you
can learn from it forgive yourself and
move on
no on the other hand if you're that type
of person like me
that always has a back-up plan for a
back-up plan it's not necessarily a bad
thing
you just need to be able to control it
better let me explain what i mean here
you need to learn how to plan really
good without worrying or stressing about
the outcome about the results
so you need to understand there's a
difference between overthinking and
planning really good planning for things
that might happen let me explain if you
think about all the possibilities of
what might happen
you can plan for the unexpected and be
ready for anything
and listen you have to plan for the
future because if you don't plan for the
future you are planning to fail so plan
for the future have your backup plans be
ready for anything
but then
once you did your best you gave it your
all 100 to plan don't worry about the
outcome because you cannot control the
outcome
even if the outcome is bad you can still
be happy with yourself because then you
know man
i've tried my best i couldn't have done
anything different and you know it's
never about the destination that makes
life so interesting it's all about the
journey because it's on the journey
where you grow and where you learn
that's where you actually have the most
fun
and if you fail it's not the end of the
world when you fall you just get back up
again if you fall again you get back up
again
just take it one day at a time and don't
over complicate things martin luther
king jr said
if you can't fly then run
if you can't run then walk
if you can't walk then crawl
but by all means keep moving
and here's the thing if you're still
young you need to understand that you
will probably fail many times in your
life
that's gonna happen
that is what it means to be a human you
will make mistakes
and then all that you do is just you get
up again that's it
the worst thing you can do is to not
stand up again because if you fail it
does not make you a failure but if you
don't stand up
then you will be a failure
now let me share this with you one of
the best weapons for me to control my
thoughts is to live in the truth
because the truth will set you free from
many things in this life that's got a
grip on your thoughts don't ever be
controlled by
what ifs or maybes
listen to this
most of the things you worry about
will never happen
now listen to this because this is
important this is how you take your
thoughts captive
you can't always control what thoughts
just jumps into your head right
but and this is key you can control
choose whether you go along whether you
continue with that thought or not
so for example if you get the thought in
your head ask yourself is this true is
it a fact well no it's just a maybe
okay another question can i control the
outcome of the situation i'm thinking
about
no i can't
another question will my worrying about
it change the outcome
no it won't
all right also i'll stop thinking about
it and replace it with other thoughts
that will be more productive
now my best weapon to never overthink
things that i cannot control
listen to this is god's spirit in me
a lot of you especially you are not
christian atheist and
you're probably thinking man daniel what
are you talking about now well just give
me a few seconds to explain this i know
by the way even if you're from another
religion or atheist it doesn't change
the way i view you i still love you as a
brother or a sister the 10 of sisters
who are watching this channel
all right but let me explain this true
reborn christians they worship god in
spirit
and in truth
and it is god then that gives them peace
jesus said in john 4 24 god is spirit
and those who worship him
must worship in spirit and truth
now yes there are many fake christians
in the world but a true reborn christian
he has been spiritually reborn
and if he is a child of god he has god's
spirit in him and it is the spirit of
god that gives him that peace that just
goes above all understanding even in
difficult situations jesus said in john
14 27
peace i leave with you my peace i give
to you not as the world gives do i give
to you
let not your hearts be troubled
neither let them be afraid
you see it is god in me that takes away
any stress and anxiety
you know i used to overthink things when
i was younger when i was not a christian
i used to think about things all the
time and stress and have anxiety and
think about my future and oh man
so exhausting
but then i became a true reborn
christian and it is god's spirit in me
that brings me peace and that guards my
heart and my mind my thoughts
in christ jesus
the bible says do not be anxious about
anything but in everything by prayer and
supplication with thanksgiving let your
requests be made known to god
and the peace of god which surpasses all
understanding will guard your hearts and
your minds in christ jesus
so for me
i just can't even begin to try and
explain to you what a purpose-driven
fulfilled peaceful life i have
because i'm spiritually alive in god
i used to drink a lot i used to be
arrogant and wasted my life by just
being selfish
but then when i lost my second brother
god spoke to me in the hospital
if you want to hear more about my
testimony you can watch this video here
it's from my other channel
and i'll see you there and before you go
always remember this
life
is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys